dude finally inception I'm a big
believer in no spoiler so I'm not
spoiling for you alright so
inception already looks really cool but
it's a summer movie season went on and
started to be about as appealing as a
donkey show featuring Bea Arthur let's
face it we were craving something good
like something really good and really
smart you know to renew our faith in
cinema luckily this is the weekend you
get it like Inception I don't even use
the term brilliant cuz I'm not British
but it was brilliant like to call
inception a summer movie or an action
movies like calling the Dark Knight a
comic book movie it just severely
undercuts it this movie is as fulfilling
as a psychological thriller as it is a
drama action movie in a mystery yeah
it's all those things I really don't
think there's a person alive who won't
at least find this movie interesting
because it deals with something that we
all do dream dream manipulation you know
you like that just be honest with
yourself like Inception is really deep
on how dreams work and the mechanics of
it all which is really cool to see these
people talk about it in the movie and it
was really cool to see how things in the
real world affect the dreams badass and
the performances in this movie were all
top-notch mean everybody brought their
a-game to the table when's the last time
you can say that about a movie I mean
honestly I honestly think the only
problem people might have with this
movie is that it takes a lot of
brainpower to keep up with it's very
involved inception just has layers upon
layers otherwise known as the makings of
a good movie but I mean let's face it
with the movies we've had lately we
haven't had our brains exercised in
cinema it's like eating a lot of junk
food for months and then suddenly
working out one day so brush up on that
brain Age I mean honestly Christopher
Nolan makes the workings of the
subconscious so realistic in this movie
you swear to God he has like a PhD in
psychology I don't know if he does I
would not be surprised and if the movie
is all and the subconscious
doesn't even work like that
well you'd be asked his way through just
fine and I bought it and so will you I
mean honestly I never even thought that
a movie primarily taken place in a dream
otherwise known as not the real world
could be so damn intense you have fun
biting your nails off in this movie I've
heard some people compare inception to
the matrix and I do see why they do that
but honestly inception makes the matrix
look like it was written and directed by
an eight-year-old and I like the matrix
the first one but I'm just saying is
inception better than the Dark Knight
that's kind of tough I might be a little
biased on that because the Joker is like
my favorite character ever however I
will say that inception is a lot more
complex and involved in the Dark Knight
I'll definitely say that this is a good
contender for best picture of the year
so far
I will phrase it like this on
eighth day God created Christopher Nolan
and on the ninth day Nolan started
making movies this movie will meet if
not surpass your expectations as
Christopher Nolan movies do because you
go in there thinking you're prepared but
you're not prepared this is the coolest
movie I've seen all year long in the
most involved movie I've seen in years I
noticed they can't wait to see what kind
of dreams I have tonight because that
shit's gonna be crazy so to all you
people out there with no imagination who
will call inception boring overrated or
lame go ahead and go watch your
transformers to slash GI Joe movie
double feature and just be content for
the rest of you go watch inception like
right now seriously why are you still
here go watch it but if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more than click right here to see more
then go watch inception
[Music]